aujourd'hui quand un tout petit enfant
de 2 ans rentre dans le bus ou dans le
métro il ne croise quasiment plus de
regard humain nous sommes tous captée
par nos écrans la révolution numérique a
déferlé dans nos vies dans nos familles
avec comme pour tout progrès
technologiques la promesse d'un monde
meilleur plus facile pour nous pour le
digital
il s'agissait de pouvoir communiquer
tous facilement les uns avec les autres
même à l'autre bout du monde et d'avoir
accès à la connaissance à l'infini tout
progrès technologiques
interroge mais celui ci encore plus que
les autres car ces outils numériques se
retrouve dans toutes les mains même dans
les mains des bébés les neurosciences
nous le rappelle pour se développer
le petit enfant a d'abord besoin de
créer un lien fort et privilégié avec
ses parents
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'attachement la
maman regard de son bébé et son bébé la
regarde le bébé sourit et le papa lui
sourit la maman fait à re et le bébé
ferreux
le bébé qui pleure et qui n'est pas bien
regarde son papa est le papa lui dit tu
pleures tu t'agites tu veux que je te
prennent dans les bras
il prend son bébé dans ses bras et le
bébé se sont sécurisés le bébé sont
combien il est important aux yeux de ses
parents il communique avec eux et c'est
le début du langage le regard humain est
un puissant stimulant du développement
de l'enfant
mais les parents sont de plus en plus
sollicités par leur écran les études
montrent que nous sommes en moyenne cinq
heures par jour sur nos écrans en dehors
du temps de travail
il ya toutes les démarches que nous
devons faire sur internet et puis les
applications de plus en plus nombreuses
vous avez les jeux vidéo les réseaux
sociaux les séries que vous pouvez
regarder en illimité les tutos et l'e
mail de votre travail qui arrive le soir
quand vous êtes en famille
cette captation des parents par les
écrans commence dès la naissance de
l'enfant à la maternité
une puéricultrice me raconte un jour
qu'elle est appelée dans la chambre
d'une maman qui vient d'accoucher
parce que le bébé pleure elle rentre
dans la chambre
le bébé pleure fort et la télé
fonctionne fort aussi elle propose à la
maman d'éteindre la télé la maman n'est
pas tellement contente parce qu'elle est
en train de regarder sa série préférée
mais elle accepte
puis la puéricultrice suggère que la
maman propose le saint lô bébé il a
peut-être fin et là la maman brandit son
smartphone devant la puéricultrice et
lui dit ah ça c'est pas possible parce
que mon appli allaitement me dit que mon
bébé n'a pas faim avons une heure les
laboratoires de lait infantile appose la
publicité de leurs applications au
dessus des tables à langer des
maternités mais donc sous les les
parents sont de plus en plus capté par
leur écran et la captation de
l'attention des parents peut entraver le
processus d'attachement et cela peut
entraîner chez les petits enfants des
troubles de la relation si l'enfant
développe une bonne relation
d'attachement
alors il va aller découvrir le monde et
il va aller explorer le monde réel en
trois dimensions avec tous ses sens ceci
va contribuer à ce qu'il continue son
développement
les sens comme la vue l'audition le
toucher le goût l'odorat le mouvement
vont envoyer au cerveau des milliards
d'informations
c'est chaud c'est froid c'est doux c'est
lourd ça pique ça tombe quand je le
lâche et sa tombe et ça casse et puis ça
sent bon ça sent pas bon ça le goût de
l'est où ça le goût de banane c'est
milliards d'informations en arrivant au
cerveau entraîne la création de plus de
1000 nouvelles connexions cérébrales par
seconde
mais l'enfant s'il est captée par les
écrans tout ce processus ne va pas
pouvoir se faire le premier écran de
petite enfance est souvent la télévision
familiale
surtout lorsqu'elle est allumée en
continu au salon ce qui est le cas chez
près d'une famille sur deux
les parents pensent que l'enfant ne
regarde pas la télé mais en fait ne peut
s'empêcher de jeter des coups de répéter
vers la télé surtout quand c'est la
publicité puis les parents proposent des
comptes
des dessins animés et des jeux éducatifs
il pense que si on propose des contenus
pour adultes c'est pas bon pour leur
bébé
mais s'ils choisissent des contenus
soi-disant adapté cela va éveiller son
intelligence et éviter qu'ils ne
s'ennuient
alors est ce que les petits enfants
peuvent vraiment apprendre avec un écran
vous avez ici une tablette éducative
vous vous savez que c'est une pomme
parce que vous l'avez découverte d'abord
avec vos sens vous savez que c'est un
fruit
quel ça se mange que c'est sur un arm
mais le petit ne peut pas découvrir ce
qu'est une pomme avec une tache rouge
il a besoin d'avoir une pomme dans les
mains il sait qu elle est ronde parce
qu'il fait le tour avec les doigts il
s'est calé lis pas ce qu il la caresse l
un poids de pommes dans ses mains s'il
essaie d'enfoncer son doigt dedans ce
n'est pas possible
contrairement à la tomate et puis elle a
une odeur de pomme et un goût de pomme
tous les sens de l'enfant lui permettent
de découvrir et d'apprendre ce qu'est
vraiment une pomme ici l'enfant ne peut
pas apprendre que c'est une pomme
surtout si elle a des yeux si elle parle
mais le docteur l'enfant peut apprendre
à compter avec un écran la tablette
montre un bâton et 10,1 et l'enfant 10 1
puis la tablette montre zigzags et 10,2
et l'enfant répète depuis la tablette
montre un ressort et 10,3 et l'enfant
répète 3 et je vois des enfants comme ça
comptait jusqu'à 50
mais si je leur dis donne moins de cube
ils sont incapables de me donner de cube
car ils ont associé par automatisme une
image un son ils ne comprennent pas ce
que je veux dire
il répète démons qui n'ont pas de sens
un jour je reçois un petit mathéo en
consultation trois ans à la demande de
la directrice de l'école car il était en
difficulté
il rentre dans mon cabinet avec son papa
je lui dis bonjour il me répond bleus je
lui dit comment tu t'appelles
il me répond rouge je lui dit assieds
toi il me répond jaune et toute la
consultation s'est fait comme ça avec
matteo qui récitait les couleurs
encouragés par un papa très fier dit le
docteur sais quelle couleur ça matteo
passait plusieurs heures par jour devant
des petites vidéos youtube qui lui
faisait répéter les couleurs jeudi au
papa je vais vous demander un seul truc
pour la prochaine fois vous arrêtez de
lui apprendre les
l'heure est bien sûr je lui parle
développement de l'enfant et impact des
écrans alors comment un tout petit
peut-il devenir accro aux écrans les
flashs lumineux et sonores rendre captif
l'enfant en sollicitant son attention
involontaire celle qui sans effort va
tous nous faire tourner la tête par là
s'il ya un flash lumineux ou par là s'il
ya un bruit soudain c'est la tension qui
nous permet d'échapper aux dangers et de
chasser tout le contraire de la tension
volontaires qu'on appelle aussi
concentration qui demande un effort du
cerveau pour faire abstraction à ce qui
bouge et fait du bruit autour de nous
pour que se concentre sur une seule
tâche c'est le petit enfant qui
construit sa tour de cube et l'enfant
plus grand à l'écran qui fait ses
apprentissages de scolaires et puis le
graphisme élaboré soigner les effets
spéciaux
l'effet waouh qu'on rajoute aux écrans
waouh vase il recommence stimule le
circuit de la récompense dans le cerveau
de l'enfant qui se met à fabriquer de la
dopamine le neurotransmetteur du plaisir
pour contrer et l'emballement du circuit
de la récompense le cerveau va inhiber
certains récepteurs à la dopamine et
l'enfant pour avoir toujours ça même
dose de plaisir va réclamer de plus en
plus l'écran l'enfant avec les écrans un
maximum de plaisir avec un minimum
d'effort exactement ce que recherche le
cerveau humain
très vite il va se détourner de tous ces
autres jouets et des humains qui
l'entourent
il ne va il ne va vouloir que les écrans
il y a quelques mois une de mes amies
vient me voir avec sa fille de 5 ans les
ans elle avait le smartphone de sa maman
à la main je ne dis rien et puis elle
était en train de faire un magnifique
bateau avec une application
je lui dis or c'est beau mais ce serait
bien que ce soit toi maintenant qu'ils
fassent ton bateau tu es d'accord elle
est d'accord je vais chercher des
feuilles des crayons et elle se met à
s'appliquer avec beaucoup d'efforts à
faire un bateau au bout de quelques
minutes elle avait dessiné des treks
était pas très droit droit où l'on
reconnaissait pas trop le bateau et puis
elle se met à colorier ça dépasse elle a
fui tellement fort ça fait un trou au
bout d'un quart d'heure elle arrête je
lui dis
c'est beau c'est bien on va l'accrocher
au frigo mais elle était déjà reparti
leur smartphone de sa maman pourquoi
voulez vous que les a sont bêtes
après un quart d'heure d'efforts à faire
un bateau pas fini mal dessinée mal
colorier alors qu'en quelques secondes
et quelques effleurement de doigt
elle fait un magnifique trois mâts sur
le smartphone de sa maman les écrans
font la place de l'enfant ce qui n'a
aucun intérêt pour lui ça l'habitude à
faire des activités sans effort or sans
effort il n'y a aucun apprentissage
possible et tout sera difficile à
l'école les flashs visuel et sonore des
écrans c'est comme un bombardement
sensorielle cela stresse le cerveau de
l'enfant le fait souffrir lieu de le
nourrir
c'est comme si nous avions une alarme
incendie allumé à côté de l'enfant
pour conclure les écrans vous vole
quelque chose de très précieux du temps
avec vos enfants et vos petits enfants
vous pouvez faire beaucoup pour eux car
vous êtes leurs premiers éducateurs pour
l'enfant commencé à limiter le plus
possible les activités sur écran car
aucune d'entre elles ne sera aussi riche
et nourrissants pour lui que les
activités du monde réel avec les
interactions humaines
quant à vous votre téléphone portable a
déjà remplacé votre montre votre réveil
votre appareil photo
ne le laissez pas remplacer votre
famille le petit enfant a besoin de lien
plutôt que de bien il a besoin d'être
entouré plutôt que d'être équipé alors à
vous de jouer maintenant
[Applaudissements]